I think if you smok cigarettes in the
backyard you're Vietnamese true I think
if you had a gambling problem or like
you know what I mean you wear like wife
featers and do videos I think if you
wear a black T-shirt and a gold chain
you're Vietnamese
basically literally that's how I knew
you were Vietnamese [__] I saw the black
shirt in the chain I'm like this is at
least
[Laughter]
[Music]
half welcome back to another episode of
careful boys today we have with us
brought to you by nectar hard
Seltzer Asian flavors with no bad
aftertaste is that correct no weird
after no weird aftertaste it's really
good I liked it courtesy of under the
influence who's here with us today we
have M we got Esther over
there thank you for coming thank you for
what were you just saying a second ago
oh I was just going to ask uh Joe and
Bart um have you guys been cancelled for
doing like Asian accents NOP have you um
you know what people do sometimes say it
cuz I actually learned the Asian accent
from you guys
so like okay like you you do like you do
kind of like a Chinese or like
Vietnamese kind of like those accents
right yeah I'm just like hello what the
[__] you mean huh and then like someone
was like you are not you're they're like
you're not vietamese what the hell you
get mared for that so people get they've
said stuff to you about that but you
have V you have a
cosign and I will say I met I met some
pretty big uh Vietnamese creators out
here and that's literally how they
talk that's how they talk yeah it's
really good actually like so thank you I
practice
well I've been watching you guys for
like so many years that it stuck to me
so now yeah now we did influence the
minds of the youth I do think the idea
that you doing and learning a Vietnamese
accent from two guys who aren't
Vietnamese is funny I thought it was
hilarious I don't think it's worthy of
being cancelled I just think it's funny
are Vietnam is adjacent maybe you got
canceled cuz you said you learned it
from them no I actually never said that
this is my first time say oh wow you're
about to get canceled sleep it out
delete it I feel like we got a pass
because we're grandfather bed into the
scene I think if you smoked cigarettes
in a backyard if V me true I think if
you had a gambling problem or like you
know what I mean you wear like white
feeders and do videos I think you wear a
black T-shirt and a gold chain your
vietnames basically [__] literally
that's how I knew you were Vietnamese
[__] I just want to tell you guys that I
love Vietnamese food so don't come after
me no but dead ass I saw the black shirt
in the chain I'm like this [__]
is at least
half give me props like I'm dating a
white girl come on like I'm know but you
know out of all the Asians though like I
feel like Vietnamese have the best sense
of humor and I never like I just felt
always welcomed by the community cuz
when Vietnamese people come out like to
meet and greets they come out and like
they you know it's a different vibe like
they love to party it's a different vibe
from like East Asians I feel like
they're one of the fun
Asians we don't have the time or energy
to complain about stupid [__] I'm
getting my ass beat every day yeah I
want to
laugh if I have to laugh at myself I
laugh right yeah we did Korean
Vietnamese we did all kinds of action
Chinese whatever right hit us with a
Korean one they just sound like they're
complaining all the time like and then
sound drag it out to like w like that's
pretty good hey I'm
Korean she's Korean where' you learn
that one this guy's giving you approval
and she's Korean I'm cosigning her yeah
he's Korean as well thank you
mother yeah I love accents me too okay
try um try black vers accent never mind
I like the
Asian that's also why I feel like you
can't get canceled if you're Asian
person doing Asian accents they're just
like oh that's allow what we get what we
can't cancel for like doing I mean we
probably will never get canceled out
here again but like white people accents
white people accents cuz I be doing it
all the time like what like what kind of
Chinese are are you that's like a
southern this is my country there's
nothing wrong with that you guys do all
could be the German Irish the Jewish the
Jewish talent agent one was the best I
don't know if I could do that again I
think that was one time je talent agent
the Jewish tal talent agent I want to
hear what that sounds like it's like
yeah it's like the person that's like uh
you're going to be a star I can't you
going to take me to
Vegas where it's not even like a oh my
God you're so silly yeah that sounds
almost more like New Yorker or like yeah
damn Jeremy love to be here also cuz
yeah no no no he's really good with
accents right so good yeah I wish he was
here also cuz I love him but like damn
he's you guys got to hook up dude when
when we used to do skits we used to
practice all the time because have to be
in character and we have to like who
knows what character we're going to play
but now I feel like we're just so Rusty
and it just it just comes out it it is
weird how it kind of evolved to like no
accents at all because in our generation
it was like if you can execute it well
clearly the 10 intention isn't just like
racist but if you came at it
like my name is Mr
wer yeah but if you did it like that
you're like bro like yeah you're just
making fun of it that's kind of that's
kind of sus right I missed the internet
when it was like like that though sh
it's so much harder to be funny now but
if you execute a good accent like
remember Russell Peters his stand a bit
like it feels like oh bro you studied
and you know us and that's like yeah
it's like you're you're laughing with us
right but these days if you do it at all
and you're not specifically that culture
then it's like yeah wrong yeah cuz like
when did when did Asians start coming
after other Asians for doing other Asian
always really oh so you're saying
accents never mind accents I think when
they get beat up at school yeah that's
true if they get beat up at school then
they get mad and they have to take it
out on someone and they blame that oh
it's because your accents they don't
like me but it's like no you're the
loser they don't like you because you're
a loser like I I can't get Mexican [__]
because they all make fun of me cuz your
guys'
videos remember when I told you I I went
to summer school with like Vietnamese
gangsters and they all were like what's
your what does Philippino language sound
like and I was about to tell them and
then they just started
going and I was like [__] sick burn
that's a sick bird they were clicking
they set you up they were like I thought
they were like going to be nice to me
and ask they were like oh what's your
name and I was about to say though is it
that is it it's like [__] dude you guys
are wait would you guys be pissed off if
that happen
to I mean it depends are you getting
ganged up on and they're being malicious
I was like out heavily outnumbered so
it's like if I don't laugh it's like
nervous laughter like Vietnamese dude's
going but what if it was just like a
white fraternity doing it to you though
oh that's I was in a white frat but yeah
you're part of the problem if they're
funny if they're funny though yes hey
you want to know what my pledge name was
too which I realized later is is racist
I mean I realized in the moment is
racist as [__] but what was it try to
guess what what my eyes no no okay not
it's a little bit more creative a little
more it's like the name of it's an
actual name so something Wong it's a
name yeah yeah something iconic in Asian
Mulan Hundai Mulan is close that sounds
pretty good wow say Hundai you know who
Nina Lynn is she came over and she she
called me Mulan in a video and that [__]
was pretty you know n she's um from New
York and she's the girl that R the um
the trash can she's the one that got all
that [__] for sounding like she's from
New York sorry sorry I was born here
yeah yeah yeah what's your plunge name
man General
s that's good that's fun though cuz I
like the general part it was it was
lowkey funny like I was like that's kind
of hilarious yeah but in a frat like
especially cuz our frat was very
Multicultural so it was always like you
got to be like you got to make fun of
this person somehow and then racist
jokes were obviously the funny but that
was also a give and take like you guys
are making fun of each other exactly if
it's a friend thing it's cool but like I
think if it's a random person then it
could be like that's disrespectful right
that's where I'm like intention is gone
you know people don't look at intention
did you go to like your fellow white
fraternity brothers and like Zig them
and
stuff I just want to make sure it was
Mutual yeah oh man but you never got any
problems for like any of these accents
throughout all those years I mean there
was I think there was one guy who was
like some activist like super super
incel and I remember him trying to Rally
up everyone and saying oh these guys
they profited for years off of the Asian
accents and you just see like him trying
to Rally up like how can people still
whatever they self their fans are
[Laughter]
of the internet and people like that
just get [__] on and I was just like
that's so funny like you're trying to
Rally up a [__] like group against us
and then everybody's just laughing at
him like oh you a [__] man you weren't
a part of the culture what about Trader
Joe's okay so you know how Trader Joe's
when they have like Asian Trader me what
do you guys think about that is that
racist it's good right is it racist or
is it f no that bring us back to the
whole thing if the product is good you
got to kind of but they also have Trader
Jose's oh yeah so it's fair game I think
it's fair game I think I thought they
did one for like every culture for like
they have an Indian one I don't know
what it's called but it's something
Indian I think that be what would that
be called tra to me it's always is it
good or not like I remember so I was in
the military and I met this one white
dude and my other homie he was Korean
and he was like yo this dude knows how
to speak Chinese I was like for reals
and he comes up to me
goes I was like dude this is pretty
funny it's more impressive than
offensive and it was just saying
nonsense but it
though it was close enough yeah I was
like dude I was like that's
F so to me it's always is it good first
you ended up doing that as a Korean
later but people these days get they get
offended like let's I'm Korean so when a
Korean person sees another like
ethnicity like wear Korean traditional
clothes they're like why how are you how
are you wearing that you're not supposed
to wear that's racist and I'm just like
okay with that no it's always Korean
Americans though it's not Korean Kore
wear that [__] D I even got yeah I got
[__] on for wearing like it's like it
looks like a chopstick on my hair but
it's basically like a Korean traditional
like pin that you put on your hair and
they and they were just like oh like
that's racist you know like why are you
and I'm just like you're a [__] white
[__] but also the internet the internet
makes it feel far worse like it's
literally if you really talk to somebody
nobody gives a [__] it's just the
loudest pussiest people of all time on
the interet it's like you just allow
them to have a connection and they will
never say it in real life so they have
to get it out on the [__] internet
cuz it's like when you weigh your
experiences from like face to face
confrontations have you guys ever had
any of those no no these basement
dwellers aren't going out they're not
going out going back to what I said if
you have the like real [__]
don't if you if somebody wants to kill
me I'm going to expect you to pop up and
I don't know about you he tells you his
location yeah I literally I used to go
on live and be like this is where I'm at
you have 30 minutes I will stay here for
30 minutes any that anybody that pulls
up and wants to fight me you can do it
no one shows up but I know I do that
knowing that all the hate comments I
have you're [__] yeah they never do you
probably just going to get a bunch of
girls showing up anyway try to touch
your
junk like hi B I said that one who hates
you I'mma beat up your
penis can I wrestle with your dick I I
told him um I used to uh I used to drop
fake addresses
I used to DM them so like haters
whatever right I used to back in my city
I used to have some people that hated me
and I would DM them like let's link up
let's fight blah blah blah but I would
send them the wrong address just like a
random address and then go to it I I
wouldn't be there and they would
actually you you knew that they went to
those addresses I don't know if they did
or not but it was just something funny
like I I got enjoyment out of this like
you're wasting your time what's some I'm
just curious like what were some reasons
people back then hated you like what was
the back in Iowa yeah uh uh I like
robbed a lot of
people valid reasons so they just want
their stuff back yeah yeah he was the
villain he was there there there have
been some situations where I the villain
but um one in that circumstance I I'll
always say like I've never hid who I was
I've always like expressed how how I did
not like that version of myself like I
don't like it when people try to shame
me for a version of myself that I had to
be to survive but also two uh there was
a lot of lot of people that hated me
because they they didn't like uh what I
stood up for or they thought I was doing
it to to to blow up or for attention or
for money so it's like I also had those
people and I would DM them and I'd just
be like kill yourself there was this one
guy that was really annoying that made a
video of him like like made like a mini
dock it was so stupid they basically
said like oh you don't stand up for
Asian but youed mhm yeah so he's like uh
he basically was trying to use me as an
example trying to play me like a hoe he
was like these these new age Asians
never stand up for their own people but
they'll stand up for like black lives
matter yeah black lives matter or like
whatever the trend is nowadays and it's
I I responded I said cuz when I was on
house arrest for for the whole BLM [__]
I I risked going back like I didn't know
if they would send me back to to jail or
not for this but I I organized in uh an
event like a memorial for the uh Atlanta
shootings when like five Asian women got
killed yeah so I did that and I I never
posted about it I like never talked
about it online cuz it's like if I do
that [__] I feel like I I want to do it
out of for the like for the right
reasons I'm not doing it for clout so
it's like it got to a point where it's
like online if I talk about this [__] I
have people saying I'll do it for clout
if I don't talk about this I have people
calling me out for you know not not
saying anything that [__] got very
annoying and even for BLM you weren't
doing it for cloud like it just happened
yeah I literally said like do not like I
don't cuz I knew if if I knew I would
get in trouble with my probation officer
if if it came to like that cuz that
violated the terms I didn't think I
would like catch that charge or whatever
but I assumed I would get like a
probation violation yeah so I was like
don't show my face I don't want my name
out there blah blah blah but during
probation you weren't even allowed to go
to like uh Mass like functions and stuff
or what my my my probation officer so my
probation officer was a woman with a
very um shaved shaved head you know you
know what I'm saying but uh she was very
Subaru yeah yeah and she was like you
can go to this as long as you don't
cause trouble and I assume you're going
to cause trouble word for word that's
what she said so it was basically saying
I'm going to tell you that you can't go
to this but in the right way so it's
like okay I said [__] you and I went and
I uh another reason was I also Wrestled
a cop and it was on at that day the same
it was the same day yeah did you win huh
no I I wasn't a cop like he he had
grabbed a person I was trying to like de
arrest him so I like I grabbed him and I
and did it work that he had to let him
you tug a war with a human being pretty
much yeah and the guy actually got away
oh good [__] and then they picked him up
later didn't help at all catch and
release yeah so I just got myself in
trouble for no reason I do like that you
talk [__] back to all the people that
say stuff to you though uh I try not to
as much nowadays but when I was on house
arrest I had nothing to do I had nothing
to making good content like my brand was
just [__] found me hot and I would
argue with people that's it for two
years straight yeah so I'd literally be
on house arrest every single day on my
phone like you feel the top of way bro
come I don't care kill yourself
so you are interesting that's a good
line that's fun that's a good Finishing
Line kill yourself is a good way to end
a sentence yeah yeah do they ever like
your comment after you said that to him
I've had a few people that are like you
know what I thought you were a [__] but
like you're kind of funny I'm like they
end up be fans after that wow and they
send you memes from now on I'll just be
like what what's the point bro go do
something with your life interesting
people that hate are are very like
contradicting too so it's just like
they're stupid that's true very stupid
like the person that was hating on him
like he was like oh you don't stand up
for Asians but it's like you are
[__] on another Asian you're Asian
and you're [__] on him bro and then
I DMD him cuz I didn't like I don't like
having my [__] to public so I dm' him
and in the dmss I'm like show me show me
what you've done and he did for to his
credit he's like donated he's organized
rallies so I'm like so word for word I
was like why are you coming at me if
we're trying to achieve the same goals
and do the same [__] he was like I
didn't know you were doing that blah
blah blah I'm like okay so why are you
posting everything you do you [__] I
like bro I'll talk to you like I wasn't
trying to come at you I'm like no you
try to play me like a hoe and I just
disproved that [__] M you try to kill
himself huh you tell him to go kill
himself yeah absolutely did he double
tap it and like it after did he said I
was thinking about SU side but I guess
I'll do it now about more he's like [__]
I like that I do the same thing I think
with like especially with the JK account
I think when people start to go off I'm
like well if you really have a point
let's talk about it in the DMS instead
of trying to perform this show for
everybody I'm like if you really want to
change my mind a lot of it feels like
clout chasing cuz I would like to know
too I would also like to know I'm open
to change my mind about something if I'm
wrong but they never they never message
nope they never do they don't care if no
one's watching I haven't gotten one
person now a lot of the times
because they don't have any following or
anything like that and they want us to
respond so they can clout Chase and
build their foll the dudes that want to
fight at the club only when the security
guards are and they take your shirt off
wait what's the point of them like
saying all of that [__] when they're
commenting off of a fake profile though
it's so they can get all the likes on
the comments it's crazy what that makes
you that makes you feel good when you're
on a fake profile too when you when you
shoot on somebody and they like your
comments you're like it feels nice
that's one of the most cowardly [__]
ever though ever yourself I think you're
a [__] dude think you're P you're just
not putting any chips on the table it's
like you want to play the game but you
don't want to put any of your own like
life in it but 90 people like my
comments so what do you have to say
about that yeah but let's see what you
look
like let's see what you look like oh
that's the worst when it's like an a non
account and it's and if they comment
about your looks I'm like oh I know I
would have torn you up like it's it's
always some anime character some [__]
game I will I will say though back in
like before I blew up I I took this [__]
past the line way more oh yeah cuz I was
so I got banned on Twitter back in like
2020 because I was actively telling my
haters to like kill themselves but also
threatening their families and like
their
babies I got banned for okay that'll get
you banned are you back on now huh are
you back on yeah but I don't like
Twitter it's too much right left arguing
it's one post is like a [__] promoting
her only fans the other is person you
should threaten their babies that baby's
like what did I
do no so what I what I used to do was if
I ever got a hate comment I would go to
their profile and stalk them learn as
much as I could if you if you had a
family member I'm in there I mean like I
said only you put this effort into like
a job or like a business so when I got
banned on Twitter it was a it was a
random Troll and I figured out he had a
son oh the next the next 50 tweets were
just like attacking his son so have you
ever have you ever seen those dudes that
are like they're like blasted in tattoos
and then when people talk [__] about
their tattoos they like they'll look up
that guy and they'll be like oh I see
that his father died in in 19 oh and
then they'll get the tattoo I saw that
I've seen that guy then it'll be like an
insulting tattoo of their dad that died
that's kind of hard that's hardcore like
I don't wow that's going the extra mile
someone who just got a tattoo getting a
tattoo is very inconvenient yo it is
what does that what does that mean Fe
every body it's a diss of someone's dad
on it says fear everyone
really scared big mistake bro I don't
know that sounds like he got it thinking
that it meant no fear but my mom read it
and she said who's your friend afraid of
and he's like what and then now everyone
got it to match I actually have no fear
tatted oh really yeah it's uh it's fear
with a line through it oh that's what he
wanted he got the opposite yeah but he
got like fear and then underlined
it he got it when he was in the military
he thought it was that it he's like a
white guy that went to Japan and got a
wrong tattoo Arana Grande with her with
her barbecue tattoo man yeah wow you
remember that thing yeah I'm old it was
she got Yakitori
t d kidding news careful boys is a brand
just kidding news is the man of smart
people the people of just kidding news
careful boys they are very smart just
kiding news the number one podcast in
the
world